intentan salvar las últimas pertenencias
que les quedan estos habitantes del
distrito de rubabu no se han Librado de
las Fuertes lluvias de los últimos días
el panorama revela casas y carreteras
destruidas debido a las inundaciones y a
los corrimientos de tierra
no tengo dinero para alquilar una casa a
mi esposo ni hijos no sé a dónde ir este
desastre ha sido peligroso para nosotros
como puede ver no me queda nada ni cama
ni casa vine aquí para trabajar
estoy a salvo Pero todas mis
pertenencias desaparecieron este tipo de
catástrofes naturales son comunes en
este país de África especialmente
durante la estación de lluvias antes de
esta temporada entre enero y abril 60
personas perdieron la vida a quien
robabo el río se vaya se desbordó a
pocos kilómetros un suceso que no deja
de
sorprenderse
mi mujer estaba junto a la ventana
cuando el agua entró en la casa se cayó
y cuando intentaba sacar a mi hijo de
casa me empujó la corriente tuve suerte
pude salir y estoy a salvo Aunque me
hice daño en las piernas por culpa de
unos árboles
según la agencia meteorológica local Se
prevé que las Fuertes lluvias continúen
Durante los próximos diez días las
operaciones de rescate avanzan pero
varias carreteras que unen la capital
con el oeste del país y por tanto con
las zonas siniestradas siguen bloqueadas
lo que dificulta la atención